recordemos que esta investigación por
blanqueo agravado de fraude fiscal se
inició en marzo cuando se conoce un
informe del senado francés que había
sido pedido inicialmente para saber por
qué el gobierno de manuel macro no
recurría con tanta frecuencia a los
servicios de la multinacional
estadounidense para tomar decisiones en
temas tan importantes como la campaña de
vacunas o la reforma de la escuela
pública y la reforma de las jubilaciones
ese informe reveló que solamente en el
año 2021 gobierno francés gastó más de
1.000 millones de euros pagando a
mackenzie pero lo que es más grave decía
el informe que en 10 años mckenzie no
había pagado un solo euro al fisco
francés en forma de impuestos por eso la
policía nacional financiera abrió esta
investigación este escándalo cayó en
plena campaña electoral dio la razón a
quienes acusan al presidente manuel
macrón de ser el mandatario de los ricos
y de los bancos en ese momento macrón se
defendió dijo que si había sospechas de
fraude fiscal había que investigar que
era la justicia a la que le tocaba
decidir pero que si había también esta
posibilidad de optimización fiscal era
porque las leyes no eran correctas y que
él había sido el primero en pedir que
estas se modificarán para controlar la
evasión fiscal